[Music]
what are my feelings about serendipity
versus gumption luck versus elbow grease
when do you give up on your dream when
you throw in the towel etc there's an
old quote that I attribute to Tom Waits
but I believe it might go back to
Socrates luck is when opportunity meets
with preparation and I've always found
that deeply moving because Megan and I
talk a lot my wife and I talk a lot
about how lucky we are
we're both blessed with whatever it is
she's beautiful and an incredible actor
and smart as a whip and and a really
talented singer I can carry a great deal
of luggage and I can experience extreme
temperatures for a long time without any
sustenance we have our gifts and somehow
our paths have taken us to places where
people said we were looking for someone
who can carry luggage we're doing a play
about a donkey you're the guy and and so
I mean so much serendipity plays into it
I I lived I chose to live like an
asshole for some years and it's a tough
choice it's it's borders on
irresponsibility you know I I would be
just this side of broke so sometimes I'd
run out of money and I'd have to borrow
a month's rent from my friend but I
would then find carpentry work and pay
my friend back so I was just this side
of being a deadbeat I was flirting with
deadbeat ISM and it's a big question in
Hollywood and a lot of people make a lot
of money off of people's dreams you know
you can pay a great deal of money for
head
shots and for acting classes and
coaching and life coaching and personal
training and all that stuff and that
they'll all tell you and and that there
are really gross people who claim to
have the secret come to my acting
workshop and I'll have three casting
directors there from you know one of
them was an assistant on fifty shades of
gray matter and whatever the case may be
it's a question people wrestle with all
the time will I ever make it is it ever
gonna happen for me
when should I throw in the towel and
move back to Cleveland and see my family
and my children and my congregation I'm
a priest with kids in Cleveland and so
all I can say is it's you know it's very
it's a very personal thing to each their
own you got to keep working hard we've
talked about having a discipline if
acting is your bag you know I always
tell people if they say how can I get my
kid to where you are I say take up
woodworking but also find whatever stage
find the biggest stage you can that you
can get on to and perform in front of an
audience whether you're doing stand-up
or theatre or musicals or sketch comedy
or start shooting stuff you know now we
live in an age where you can literally
start your own TV channel right now
using your gadgets and and just let the
world tell you you know shoot videos
show them to people and they'll tell you
if you should keep doing it and if
you're good if something's meant to
happen when when people see you on stage
or they see your videos they'll say holy
you know what I'm going to somehow help
you you're gonna that was amazing I did
you can tap dance you can play the tuba
that face you make whatever it is I've
never seen anyone drink that much beer
in 90 seconds I'm gonna call my friend
he has a
show called jackass we're gonna get you
on your way and so I mean I started in
the theater I was terrible at acting I
wanted to be an actor I thought I had
something that I could entertain people
so I got into theater school in Illinois
and I was terrible I couldn't get cast
with good reason the reason was I didn't
trust myself I thought I was boring so I
was from the country and so I tried way
too hard to be someone cooler than
myself which of course just was what
they call bad acting but I was able to
build scenery I was very athletic so I
choreographed fights and the theater
paid me I found but there's so many jobs
you can do in the theater you can work
in the box office you can sell
concessions you can sweep there are many
places almost anywhere you would want to
work in a creative position you can
start there sweeping and curate your
sweeping don't don't look down on if
somebody's like well you could start as
a janitor if you want to work at Nike
and you can get in there as a janitor in
people how creative your sweeping is
nobody ever moved that cabinet move that
damn cabinet and sweep under it and let
someone be like oh yeah I just I assume
that's that everyone has the quality of
work that I do let people see how
committed you are to to exceptional work
when people because when you don't do a
good job sweeping I noticed that too and
I say I'm not gonna trust that person on
their own they always need to be told to
move the cabinet and sweep under it so I
mean if you maintain that sensibility it
makes you first of all make sweeping a
lot more fun sweeping can be drudgery or
it's an opportunity to like have fun
whistle a song in your head you can
dance with a broom they're really fun in
fact maybe that's a video line I should
think about putting out all different
genres of music all different brooms
sweeping for pleasure but when you once
you do that once you are locked into
that mindset then you are open to what
opportunity comes along you've done the
work you know if somebody wants to cast
me as a superhero
this is sort of a truism in my life I've
often said I'm athletic but I have often
carried 30 or 40 extra pounds and I
think man I'd love to play a superhero
and if someone would cast me then I'll
go to the gym and get super buff well if
I would just go to the gym and maintain
a discipline there then when someone
said oh he's funny and he's the right
type for the superhero and check out
those crazy lats that then the work is
done
that's what's so serendipity involves
serendipity has greatly helped by by
elbow grease and that reminds me of
another quote from Thomas Jefferson I
think that I won't remember good luck
something in the vein of good luck is
hard to come by but but when I work hard
I find I'm much more susceptible to
experience luck he didn't say that I
said it nick offerman said that quote
put that on a coin
[Music]